it's so lovely to see you again after
that ferocious feline chased you off I
never thought you'd leave your country
cottage hmm yes I don't much care for
the city but I really needed to buy some
Stilton cheese the country mouse is on
to something cities allow for large
markets that provide specialized
products like gourmet treatments you
can't buy fancy cheese or much else
that's good in the country no no I've
got Amazon Prime I can order almost
anything else online Amazon Prime is a
great example of how transportation and
logistics can deliver a wide range of
products across America and the world
you can't sample cheeses when shopping
online and there aren't great
specialized services like whisker waxing
salons out in the country but when I
order online I can avoid crowds I hate
lines and I hate traffic the average
commute time for a New York City
resident is 40 minutes the average
commute time in Montana is just 18
minutes I just listen to music when I'm
stuck waiting well I have a short
commute and I can hear the crickets at
night true you don't have to deal with
traffic but jobs pay more in the city on
average wages go up by about five
percent as metropolitan area density
doubles sure you make good money but
what about housing I'd never pay such
sky-high rent housing prices also
typically go up by about five percent as
metropolitan area density doubles yes
but I have the best museums shows and
restaurants this cafe is very nice city
dwellers basically share the fixed costs
of supporting a variety of cultural
institutions urban density also
increases the bump rate the chance of
meeting someone new and exciting but
cities are dangerous I always feel safe
in the city there are so many eyes on
the street crime is an unfortunate
reality of American cities but most have
become a lot safer since the 1980s in
fact New York City has a lower murder
rate in the country as a whole
and really the best thing about cities
is the endless novelty the new
opportunities the new ideas the new
rodents it's all so exciting
give me my warm safe cottage any day
okay but while you're visiting want to
catch a show you know cats is playing